Helen says is it okay to wallow and
sadness or anger sometimes I think that
positive thinking while not feeling
positive is bottling up my emotions um
man I don't think it's ever good to
wallow in the negative feelings it's
again like the negative feelings are a
symptom the anger is a symptom the
depression is a symptom
I think there's any be recognized but
like to sit there and just wallow and
self-pity is I don't think that's useful
personally no I and I think it can it
can turn into a downward spiral I mean
like I said this and thankfully this is
on patreon this is not stuff I would
talk about and in public generally but
this past weeks first time I live have
had suicidal thoughts and I tend not to
be a motive person like the last time I
I cried legitimately like broke down a
crowd my mom died yeah a decade ago and
something I think crying is wrong I
think it's very beneficial that it just
it's not a natural response for me but I
could not stop crying this week yeah I
had to lock myself in the bathroom I was
just like sitting on the floor just i
uncontrollably and wallowing in that
though could only lead to one place
right its first time I like yeah they're
over the last time was there been times
where I'm like man I wish I wouldn't
have woken up today that's not suicidal
but there are there have been moments
where it's just been like I need to end
this all like this is too much suffering
yeah and and I need this to be over but
if if I wallow in it it's probably going
to lead to that and and so it's finding
a way out but also not I don't know sure
cuz everything's great right but but I
do want to I want to acknowledge how I
got there I need to find a way out of it
and wallowing is not it's not the answer
yeah I agree I would say it is okay for
you to process those feelings and to
take as much time as you need to process
them it is okay for you to be honest
with yourself and others about how you
feel it is okay for you to take longer
than what the people in your life think
you need
process them it's okay for you to seek
any help from anybody that you find
helpful it's okay to be curious about
those feelings it's okay to inquire into
them it's okay to use them as a tool for
self-discovery it's okay to talk to a
therapist if that's something that
you're open to and you feel is helpful
it's okay to simply feel those feelings
and not force them out of your system
overnight
that is absolutely okay I think the
reason that we take issue with the word
wallow is not because we're trying to be
the semantics cops and a rescue for
using that word it's because that sort
of implies that I'm going to accept this
as my final state and and I'm not gonna
be open to the possibility that this
feeling is going to move me in a
direction that leads me beyond it don't
accept any filling as the final state
even even the Goins that you have right
because you know all of those feelings
will subside and in many ways they are
like the seasons they come and go in
different cycles but as long as you are
in that filling give yourself to
permission to to accept that as okay for
you to fill and process that in whatever
way works for you yeah you know it's
sometimes - like when I get you know
really down for whatever reason
sometimes I will take a moment to like
really honestly appreciate the fact that
I even have the the ability to fight
rather feel pain than nothing at all you
know I mean personally I'm sure that's
different for for a lot of people but I
know that like sometimes like going
through those emotions like yeah we can
learn from it and you don't want to
stuff stuff down because like you try to
you try to like ignore those emotions it
just comes back stronger in different
ways especially like you try to drink it
away or you know do some drugs to push
it away like it's just gonna come back
even stronger um but but yeah like I was
even I was having this conversation with
Mariah this morning she was having a
rough time and I'm like you know I was
like our podcast today is about positive
thinking and like I don't think that
fixes everything but being able to a
like appreciate the fact that you have
this human experience also understanding
that the human experience it's like it's
heaven and it's hell like it's black I
think that if hell exists like this
actually might be a man you know what
I'm saying well yeah
let's actually let's unpack that a
little bit because we have someone like
Rob Bell who's been on our podcast who
and we've had quite a few Christians I
don't know
TK your son of a pastor ray son of a
preacher man okay yeah yeah so so but my
first thought goes to let you to Ryan
and I grew up religious right Ryan Jones
witness I grew up Catholic and very
religious parents but there are times
where I kind of think of I think of
prayer as almost like positive thinking
in a way but but but uh it can lead to
like can have the same sort of
delusional positive thinking we're
asking we're asking the universe to give
me the students so what you're saying is
is relying on prayer alone is kind of
like relying on positive thinking alone
right yeah it's like relying on the
secret yeah all right well it's funny
cos prayer though if you like going back
to the woop I guess the what's your wish
like that's the first step I get that
tweet that link to the song oh my god
not to know but like that's the first
step in woop there's like what is your
wish what do you want I mean and it's
you know I do think that that step is
important like you do gotta have Hail
Mary you know like I mean it's okay to
put it throw them a hell mail Hail Mary
out there like it's not but if you're
just relying on the hill what he'll Mary
is literally a prayer right that's why
the play is called a Hail Mary I know
and my mom kept rosary beads on her at
all times
and said the Rosary every sing like on
these two fingers cuz she would go
through the Rosary yeah right and and in
doing that like yeah she was she would
do the Hail Marys and that to me isn't
more of a that's like Transcendental
Meditation right like when you're going
through that same prayer over there was
sixty beads on a rosary bead I think she
just keep going through it over and over
that that's that's similar to having a
mantra and whatever your
entre is Big Blue Book or something
you're like saying it over and over and
over like it's it seems really similar
but our friend Adam Dressler who wrote a
book I think it's called this is how we
pray
yeah and it's he's a pastor a really big
Church in Tennessee and you know I'm
reading that and his is much his much
different from that like my mom's was a
meditative sort of experience but what
about prayer for you
TK what yeah I've never heard you talk
about religion but I know you have you
have your set of beliefs what are you
comfortable talking about with our small
patreon audience here always comfortable
talking about anything that comes up so
there's a very excellent book by brother
Lawrence called
the practice of the presence of God and
in that book he delivers an
understanding of prayer as the art of
cultivating a consciousness of the
divine omnipresence meaning that God is
present in and through everything and
everyone and prayer is simply anything
that we do that awakens our
understanding to this reality this is
echoed in another book Anthony de Mello
called sadhana and in that book he
begins with the premise that prayer can
and should be fun
and that any act can be prayer as long
as you are coming to attention right you
also see this echoed in Teresa Avila's
interior castle there's a verse in the
Bible that that instructs people to pray
without ceasing now if you think about
that in a literal sense that's kind of
impossible because you can't be engaged
in an act of prayer as traditionally
understood at every single moment of
your your life you have to sleep you
have to drive a car you can't always be
you know making the sign of the Cross or
holding your rosary beads or saying a
hammer or the podcast if you're printing
right um but but but but the idea of
praying without ceasing means that you
are in a state of mindfulness right
listening the world around you yeah for
me the the most sort of euphoric state
is often for me
is when I'm writing because real writing
is just noticing and then focusing that
what you've noticed into the the words
on the page right yeah absolutely
so we often conflate the distinction
between prayer as a practice and
specific forms of prayer as techniques
and there are a whole bunch of different
forms of Prayer throughout the history
of religion even in the Christian
tradition alone so the Hail Mary is a
kind of prayer but that's different from
the Our Father and both of those belong
within a specific category of Prayer
right and there are different categories
of Prayer in different examples of
Prayer the Spiritual Exercises of st.
Ignatius for instance is an entire book
on different kinds of Prayer or the
Anthony de Mello book on sadhana
every single chapter is a kind of prayer
there is even a kind of prayer that
simply involves being attentive to the
inflow and outflow of breath and
recognizing that that too is the
circulation of the divine right there
are all these different types of Prayer
so I I think just like with positivity
you have to make a distinction between
positive psychology which is this field
where lots of people disagree there's
lots of diversity there's no single
monolithic conclusion and the easy to
pick on idea that says you should only
think about what makes you feel good you
have to do that same thing with prayer
prayer is this old old ancient tradition
that has transformed many people's lives
that has been used in many different
ways across cultures and religious
traditions and then there's prayer as we
have been taught which is shut your eyes
really tightly you know close your hands
and and do petitionary prayer where you
treat God as Santa Claus and you list
out specific things that you want and
you say God give me these things and
give me these things that is one form of
prayer but that's not the only game help
me win the game give me the nice car and
the bigger house right yeah
please and yeah and yeah I think I think
that's a good point there's noticing
verses as you said petitioning you know
I often think that we turn to prayer and
the darkest moment not in the
appreciative moments right where it's
like well how this is all going great
must because I'm awesome right and but
us is all going terrible must be because
God hasn't helped me out right right um
so I just need some help guys it's
interesting you you put that perspective
on it because like I do pray but I don't
ask for stuff anymore
like I it's for its it's to show
gratitude it might be to help myself
focus on what it is that I want to
incorporate into my life whether it's I
don't know man like wanting to live a
healthier lifestyle and I will like
voice my want but it's not asking like I
don't like you know it's not like hey
program me go inside my brain and
program me it's more about like hey
thanks for giving me the opportunity to
you know change these things but that's
that's how I look at prayer but um I
guess it's another way it's a long way
of saying like for me prayer is it used
to be this yes give me gimme gimme help
me help me help me and now it's a like
gratitude practice that I have and it's
like the things that I do want yeah I
mean if I could if there was a Santa
Claus that I could ask tough or like
yeah I guess maybe I would ask for stuff
but really like the ones that I have why
just put myself in God shoes and like if
I was God I would want me to do it
myself like I would want I would want me
to like put as much effort into it and
like for me to go through the struggle
for me to not just have things handed to
me so given notice a parenting now like
with Ella it'd be much easier for me to
make her bed in the morning than
coaching her through it repeatedly Ryan
orale whatever it is it's like I could
say give me I'll do it right but that's
what's that going to do it's going to
just enable her to keep asking Santa
Claus to do the thing for her right and
just like this weekend she was she was
doing something with a little tablet
that she has and she was like come over
here and help me with it I'm like no you
come over here and I will help you with
it if I'm not doing
something right now right I'm gonna help
you figure it out I'm not gonna come
over there and fix everything for you so
there's a very interesting Bible story
that mirrors that so there's a story of
Jesus and the disciples on the boat and
there's a great storm and it causes the
disciples to fear for their lives Jesus
is sleeping on the boat according to the
story and the disciples run to him and
they say they wake him up and they say
Jesus we fear for our lives we're gonna
die
save us and Jesus's response is very
interesting based on religious
stereotypes alone what you would expect
from Jesus is for him to say something
like well done my good and faithful
servant you have come to your God in a
time of great distress and you have made
a request of me and allow me to help you
out but that's not what he says he
rebukes them and says o ye of little
faith
how long must I tarry with thee then he
addresses the win in the waves and he
says peace be still and the storm ceases
and then they say what manner of man is
this that even the wind and the sea obey
Him and whenever you hear that preached
about or talked about usually the
emphasis is on how powerful Jesus was by
making the storm cease but we kind of
overlooked the fact that he rebuked his
own followers when they reacted to a
crisis by running to him and begging him
to save them he responded to them as if
it were his will for them to develop
their own potential to do something
about it in the Eastern Orthodox
Christian tradition one of the words
that's used for salvation is stay osis
which means God becoming and and it
follows the pattern of one of the early
church fathers who said God became man
so that man might become God and the
notion there is the goal of prayer is
self-actualization it's divinization
right that the goal of prayer is to not
increase this sense of dependency that
causes us to constantly make posit
petitions save me give me gimme it's to
increase that sense of independency
where we sort of reclaim our
understanding of what it means to be
made in the image and likeness of the
Creator where we awaken to our own
creative power our own creative
potential and we can fulfill the command
that was given in Genesis where God
creates the world and says I'm gonna
stop now I'm handing the project over to
you be fruitful and multiply take this
world and make it more than
it was when I gave it to you
you